- I got my shit in the right perspective
and you just go.
Once you realize it's like all gravy,
it gets real easy.
(phone ringing)
- [Man On Phone] Hello!
- Yo.
- Yo, it's GaryVee!
- [Man On Phone] What's up Gee!
- How are you my man!
(man on phone laughs)
- [Man On Phone] I really appreciate that.
I've been doin' good man.
I'm building a brand,
and I'm watching the show,
really appreciate the hustle
that you put in and the extent to which,
this is what gets me man,
the detail in which you document your life
is the most amazing thing.
I love #AskGaryVee, but for me
DailyVee is the litmus test.
That's where the rubber meets the road.
(upbeat music)
♫ We're unstoppable
♫ Oh oh
(recorded voice in background)
♫ They gon' try to freeze
you when you heatin' up
♫ They gon' hold you back
'cause they ain't keepin' up
♫ But you never let 'em in
♫ Never let 'em in
- Yeah, I mean true Eric,
but there's a reason
they go there from a business standpoint,
and look I'm not gonna do anything
that I don't believe in and
I'm not anywhere there yet,
I'm just tryin' to figure
out how I wanna do this
to make us win, you know what I mean.
♫ Oh you know what's right for me
♫ But you don't live my life
♫ Somethin' bout that
You know there's two sides of every coin.
It's grass is greener, right.
You go one way, and you get one result.
You go the other way,
you get another result.
You know what I mean.
And so, and that's why I'm
always tryin' to do things
in some weird clone or
things of that nature,
because you're tryin'
to find the hack, right.
These things are so cliche.
You know what's amazing
about this stuff Eric
from a businessman's
standpoint is these things
are all fucking cliche--
They're either A or B.
- [Eric] Right.
- And if you're on Team
A, you're always like,
oh fucking B's awesome
and better and I wish,
and if you're on Team
B, you're like, fuck,
and you know, so I get it.
- [Eric] Uh huh.
- I'm just tryin' to hack
it through, you know.
♫ Keep them shooters round me
It's the biggest thing I have to unwind.
I like pounded my chest--
- Yeah, yeah.
- And like took off my
shirt and I'm like our,
are smart, and (mumbles) I
fucked the whole thing up.
But I'm excited to fix it.
I just had a call with Eric Fulwiler,
who runs the London
office, VaynerMedia London,
super-excited about blowing
out VaynerMedia London's
business next year, really excited about,
we've got the Fortune 50 companies,
but really looking forward to getting
some of these kind of like
30 to 50,000 pound a month
clients in the UK,
so looking for that action.
(faint speaking) excited about that.
Recording some right
hooks for the podcast.
- Cool.
- Let's do it.
- Start out with check
out the Facebook slash,
ask aren't you watching?
- Hey guys thank you so much for listening
to these podcasts.
Also wanted to tell you
guys about my new YouTube
channel, YouTube.com/garyvaynerchuk.
GaryVee, YouTube channel is the DailyVee,
Monday through Friday,
GaryVaynerchuk is where
I'm putting my keynotes, business clips.
Not sure if this is the right strategy,
may close GaryVaynerchuk one day
and put it all back in
one channel, but for now,
this is what I'm doing.
Go check it out.
Remember don't listen to what I'm saying,
watch what I'm doing, so hopefully
can bring some value for
some of you guys out of this.
Hi guys, today's a weird day.
Here's the meetings.
You know, a little bit blurry,
but basically client,
client, client, client,
internal, internal, internal,
stuff that I can't share with you.
Mainly, client, client, client.
It's an interesting week for the vlog
because it's just a lot of
stuff that I can't show,
but obviously, you just
heard the London call,
fun for you guys to see
how I manage other offices.
You saw me jamming on the podcast.
I'm super-excited about it.
If you're a fan of this vlog,
please get on my podcast.
I'm bringing real fucking fire there,
and you know, had a really
interesting talk last night
at Bloomberg.
Have you thought about
monetizing your voice?
That's incredible!
And that's it.
Going to hustle, going to work.
Yom Kippur's coming
tonight, so no eating for me
which is normal.
Fuck this food.
And so moving on my merry way.
Oh, really, really excited
about the Jets Jacksonville
game this weekend.
You'll be watching us after the fact,
and so my prediction is Jack 23, Jets 16.
See ya!
- [Announcer] And the
Jets win at 23 to 20!
- [Gary] Hey brother.
- [Man] How you doin'?
First one.
- So you two, this is basically
how we write articles.
This very handsome man, Colin,
C-squared, Colin Campbell,
takes the humph from a
talk or a piece of content
somewhere, then he follows
up with some questions.
I answer them, turns it to first person,
dah, dah, dah, where to we go?
- What is your definition
of a great story?
- To me a great story invokes a reaction.
The end.
You know it's kind of like
surprising the audience.
Like the flowers today.
And this is where you cut
in of you going through
the main floor with lots of flowers.
(soft music)
And PureWow too, down there.
Oh, PureWow didn't get flowers, did they?
No, they're probably super-sad.
Anyway, so it's like the flowers,
they were unexpected today,
but if today was Valentine's Day,
they'd be a little bit more expected.
So you're hacking the norm.
In Hollywood, you're
making a two-hour thing
that's gonna be played on
a big screen in a theater,
right, or in, you know,
and that's the room.
In social, it's something
that somebody's gonna watch
in their phone, while
they're in the subway,
eating a fucking burrito.
Like, you gotta think
about them differently.
You know, how much does
a big movie cost now?
- [Colin] 200 to 300
hundred million dollars.
- Good.
Spending 300 million dollars,
if you make back 900 million
dollars is a good idea.
Just spending 180,000 to make
back 40,000 is a bad idea,
which is why for most of
us who aren't Jay Jay,
(laughter)
and have those budgets, I
think we should be smart
about how much we spend and build up.
You know, just fucking practicality,
but the value is you know,
a captive audience for three hours,
that's going to spend
$16.00 a head, you know,
and buy ancillary fucking
t-shirts and buy fucking mugs
and I got a fucking
Trubaca mug here somewhere,
I don't know, like this
is the answer to why
you spend that kind of money.
Because when you spend, making
little pieces of content,
you can sell this, which is great!
Which is great!
But when you do it right, and you spend
a hundred million dollars ten times over
and you make this, there's
a drillion of this sold.
Like a drillion dollars, right.
You know, it's bigger bets,
bigger wins, bigger losses,
and it's about the practicality of it.
So there's huge ROI, I mean,
if you make where's the beef,
or just do it, or MasterCard priceless--
it's fucking game changing.
- Yeah.
- The problem is 99 percent
don't and they waste
real fucking money and my
big thing is like do this,
now I'm in a position to make bigger bets.
We can actually now,
like it's crazy to me,
what I'm about to say, we
could all have an offsite
again, a couple of
episodes ago, check it out.
(jazz beats)
Maybe in that offsite, we're like,
lets make a $200,000 documentary.
We can do that now.
But I couldn't do it before.
So build up, build up, build up.
♫ They gon' try to freeze you
It's goin' well?
♫ They gon' hold you back
'cause they ain't keepin' up
♫ But you never let 'em in
♫ Never let 'em in
How are you?
Hey Olivia.
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, how are things?
Bullshit and play on metrics 'cause
I'm not gonna take that.
I'll tell you about the thing I care about
which is, you know, if my
family business in Melbourne,
if need to sell shit,
like what are we gonna do?
♫ But you don't live my life
♫ Somethin' bout that ought
♫ Seein' as you don't know my sight
♫ My likes my dislikes
my battles my long fights
♫ My struggles my cold nights
Enter nation.
Sorry, Ro.
- Okay.
- It's Romy, I love her.
You've been here what four years, five?
- Four years and change, yeah.
- Four years and change, see.
I'm on my shit.
I mean I've been working
on a secret project.
There's nobody in
VaynerMedia that even knows
what I'm about to tell you about,
but I'm super-excited about it,
and I want my Facebook and
my Linkedin and my email
list and my super-phone and all those
to get this first.
So a lot of you have
heard about the 4D's thing
where you come in and
you learn what we do here
at VaynerMedia.
It's a little bit different.
I'm obsessed with the concept of (beep)
which is what Romy and I are working on,
which is really this
thesis of how do you make
people obsessed with?
Like why is avocado toast happening?
If you're a farmer right
now of a cranberry juice,
you wanna make your
cranberry juice bigger,
but what if you got all of America
to care about cranberry
juice and then you felt
the effects of?
You here me talking about culture hacking.
We've produced two products.
(tape speeds up)
- It's only processed when you leave.
There's nothing that we
know that you don't get
at the end of these ten hours.
- And unlike any other video I made,
we're finishing the touches
on actually pricing this shit,
so you don't even know
the price right now,
but I'm sure in this email
and in the Facebook post,
and when you ultimately click, sign me up,
the information will be there shortly.
- Right.
- We'll see you soon.
- Yeah, sounds good.
(chattering)
- Hi.
- Hi, Ann Hawkins.
- Hey everybody, this
is GaryVee, Nerd Shock,
and this is Episode 267
of the #AskGaryVee show.
That's 10, seven.
- Got it.
- I have a wonderful guest.
We just finally got to meet in real life.
His energy is legit.
So I'm excited for your my friend.
R-squared is as I'm gonna call you.
From my standpoint, it's at a macro,
everyday at a macro.
I care about what the
end-consumer gives a shit about.
When I get to the execution of something,
it's a little bit more micro.
It's a little bit more about me.
I know that mobile video
matters at a macro, right,
but when I make the content,
it's about what's artistic
and creative for me to make.
I'm just understanding what
the pillars of conversation
in culture and the places they consume
that content are, and so at a macro them,
at a micro me.
What a vlog, good day.
3:36, heading into another client meeting.
Pretty productive.
We got a little bit more out of today
than we thought we would.
A lot of good stuff,
so thinking about that.
Hope you're enjoying the vlog.
I'm enjoying your comments.
Please leave a comment
in the YouTube section.
Please pass on the subscription.
This is the call to action
to pass on the subscription.
Which one hommie?
Which one friend?
Which one parent, teacher, mentor, mentee,
individual out there should
be watching DailyVee?
Put 'em on now.
♫ Alert to confuse them
♫ Jealousy not cute
♫ Nothing is pretend
♫ And before we get Star Wars
♫ May the force be with me contour
I've got a fucking Trubaca
mug here somewhere.
This is the answer to why
you spend that kind of money.